welcome back to uncensored with me
Rosanna Lockwood now it was 60 years ago
today that over a quarter of a million
Americans descended onto the streets of
Washington DC to hear these words from
civil rights activist Dr Martin Luther
King
that one day
this nation will rise up
live out the true meaning of its Creed
we hold these tools to be self-evident
that all men are created each other
now if Dr King was to look at today's
America some say he might wonder whether
his dream has been realized just this
weekend police in Jacksonville Florida
said they believed the killing of three
black people by a 21 year old white
gunman was racially motivated the
incident has been condemned by all sides
including by the family of Dr King so
I'm pleased honored rather to say I'm
joined by Dr Martin Luther King's niece
alvida King and by Sharita Tate the
cousin of George Floyd and president of
the George Floyd Foundation thank you
ladies and here in the studio by talk TV
contributor Esther Krakow joining us
once again and author and playwright
Bonnie Greer
well what a strong panel to discuss this
and Bonnie I will actually start with
you because you were just sharing your
um original memories from Dr Martin
Luther King's speech was certainly an
rdb on with all of you expect one of Dr
King's relatives and I have to say I was
a young teenager when this when this
thing when the March on Washington and
they cleared the channels it never
happened before this was a special so we
came home from school eating our milk
and cookies and then they said Dr King
was going to be on it and we've grown up
watching Dr King as little kids were
going like okay it was cool but okay and
he was 16th down on the the speakers
Rostrum
this guy got up there we listened to the
speeches my uncle drove his truck there
we were all sitting there what they
don't tell you is that this speech was
impromptu he riffed this speech nobody
knew this was coming out of him he made
this up on the spot and you if you watch
his body you can see that was coming
through him if you saw it live you could
feel that this was like coming through
him I mean people were screaming and now
we sort of think of the speech as a kind
of iconic set piece it wasn't this was
off the cuff and that made it even more
exciting all from the heart all from the
heart alvida listening in on that
relative of Dr Martin Luther King he
must be used to hearing those types of
accounts now of what it meant to people
but do you think the words that he spoke
that day have been realized
unfortunately our collection has failed
in that sense then I will go to sharida
and ask you the same question obviously
not a relative of Dr King yourself but
the words have rung true for a lot of
Americans a lot of black people around
the world not just Americans do you
think that the words have been realized
in today's society
I'll still think that we have uh a lot
more work to do before we could say his
dream was truly realized I mean there
have been some progress but in some
cases as you can see what's happening uh
all over the country as we continue to
lose uh lives senselessly it just seems
like it takes us a step backwards
institutionally do you feel like the
support is there in order to achieve the
the kind of change that is needed and
I'm talking here from government but
also social movements as well
well I think that there are times when
we feel like that uh collectively the uh
social movement is is something that I
definitely believe is in moving in the
right direction there are times when in
general it feels like uh we have the
support uh it sort of wax and wings but
I think um we uh need to whenever we
have those times when it feels like
we're all in sync it's when we have to
really rally together and push the
narrative forward how do it affect like
the Jacksonville shooting how does that
impact you when you hear that it was
racially motivated
well it's like
um unfortunately uh it's happening so
often that it's not something that has
shock value anymore it just seems that
their their overall seems to be this uh
diminished value on the lives of black
and brown people and so when you hear
these incidents happening over and over
again uh there's no shock but what it
does do for me and I think many other
people in the movement it just pushes us
more to say there's still more work for
us to do
Let's cross back over to our video I
think we've managed to reestablish the
connection of you back with us alvida
yes I am can you can you hear me I hope
you can we can we can thank you so much
for making okay thank you so much for
making time it's been a busy few days
for you the 60th anniversary of Dr
King's uh remarks and I'll just ask you
once again where do you feel like he
would be satisfied by some of the
progress that's been made or not at all
at this point
I was a teenager uh in the 1960s I got
married in 69 and one thing that my
uncle would say we must learn to live
together as brothers I'll let as sisters
or Parish together schools and he's in
his own speech he said add righteousness
and Justice together he talked about a
check of insufficient funds so those are
some of the things and some of that is
definitely still here today he also said
we must learn to live together as
brothers and sisters and we are one
blood and one human race that we're not
separate races I think he would want us
to remember that the other point and I
hope it doesn't freeze you have to do
this in every generation every decade
and on every platform because if you
forget your if you don't if you erase
your history you're going to repeat it
again so that's why all this stuff about
burning the history books and locking
all the black kids in the classroom away
from everybody else and telling them
this is happening in Florida as well
there's a school and the black principal
agreed to have the black kids put in
their own separate classroom no you
don't separate you come together act
like human beings and learn human
dignity and to care about each other
that's something Martin Luther King Jr
talked about in that speech cash in that
check for insufficient funds dealing
with racism and uh systemic racism laws
that are written into our laws totally
opposite he said he had a dream that's
rooted in the American dream yeah that's
in that speech so you have to remember
these things but you have to deal with
it yes I agree with the other speakers
there's more to be done and it must be
done in every generation Bonnie in the
studio really quickly I was a teenager
in the 60s too and and I can say on one
hand absolutely uh things progress has
been slow but in the 1960s I would not
have dreamed of a black man being tutor
my father wouldn't have imagined that he
could not have imagined that okay he
could not have imagined a black woman as
Vice President of the United States that
would not have been possible for my
father my father was from Mississippi
that was impossible and my friend is the
director general of the Smithsonian and
that was something my father couldn't
have imagined so I agree with everybody
every generation we got to start over we
got to let people know what progress has
been made but also know that there is a
long long way to go a long way to go
well it starts sitting in the studio
here representing the British side of
things they're singing from you know
we've got three strong black American
voices here talking about this saying
we've got a long way to go still what
does it mean to you to hear that no I
think they're they're absolutely right
and obviously like I say Britain is not
American and there are different issues
but there are some similarities I mean
obviously when we talk about police
brutality in the US we can't map for
that context onto onto Britain because
it's completely different the social
dynamics and and the internet racial
Dynamics are completely different but
they are right in the sense that there's
always work to be done and there's you
know every generation has to fight for
for its place and fight for the renewal
of its values and I think that's
important in the case of Britain
obviously we have different types of
issues uh you know
discrimination and injustices are
usually linked with social class as
opposed to just race or you know just
ethnicity and so it's a different
struggle but there are underlying
similarities um in the sense that every
generation must continue to reiterate
that the values that keep us to keep us
progressing and keep us together and I
think it's you know it's obviously an
honor to be here with Bonnie it's an
honor to be with you and it's an honor
to hear
um that the Young Voices also know that
every generation has to take Dr King's
words and make them their own not only
take the words but make the words their
own and never forget the ancestors
because of
all the struggle that the ancestors
Let's cross to Alvada for the final
words then on that Aveda if you were to
take any of the words that Dr King spoke
that people should make their own which
would they be
I am a guardian of the King Family
Legacy my daddy Reverend A.D king daddy
king mama and all of them so we are one
blood One race with powerful beautiful
ethnicity let's learn to celebrate it
and stop killing each other that is a
good strong words uh thank you very much
alveda King Sherita as well joining us
thank you also for your insights uh on
this and also here in the studio we've
had Esther and Bonnie chime in on this
it's been great speaking to you all I've
learned a lot uh Bonnie particularly
about your experiences as a teenager
listening to that and how it's inspired
you
you know I want you to see something
like that and it is important to know
that he didn't he did that on the spot
yeah and that's what was so powerful
about it doing it on the spot that's
what it's all about from the heart thank
you to all of our Palace